to start here
picking a project to serve as a
follow-up to a very impressive feature
debut has to be a very high pressure
situation there you know like i can't
imagine saying no to a stephen king
adaptation with blumhouse involved but
in addition to that maybe why did you
feel like firestarter was the right next
move for you as a director you know it
was a a project that
he just first of all right a stephen
king thing i mean you know what are the
odds where the you know it's it's a
funny
i in 2017 i was at the overlook film
festival is the inaugural event it was
at mount hood where they the shining
hotel
and
i was in the audience when jason blum
and akiva
announced they were making fire starter
i was just a fan just at a festival as a
fan and i was in the third row and i
turned to my friend i was like that's a
good idea like fire started be cool
and you know here we are
five years later and that's the movie i
made it's it's kind of a strange thing
like who would have expected it
at the same time that was one of my
favorite stephen king novels and it was
certainly one of the first ones i read
it was one i identified with i have a
lot of kind of other weird connections
to it in that
before filmmaking i was in clinical
research and i used to do drug studies
like the lot 6 trial
um so
it just spoke to me in a certain way and
i thought okay
i c i could make a version of this that
that both leaves the original
1984 adaptation intact um and it goes
off in its own direction so
i don't know it just kind of all came
together so even with your prior
experience what part of the production
process on this movie which i have to
imagine is a much bigger production
maybe a higher budget than the visual
sure what what kind of came with the
biggest learning curve for you something
new or different about the way you make
a movie of the scale yeah i would say
you know the effects the effects are
definitely a big piece it's just
the amount of planning and preparation
that go into it we you know
more than 90 of the effects overall in
this film are practical um and then for
the fire stuff it's not more than 95
practical and so in order to do that you
just it's just very
in-depth conversations very early on
um and decision making you know you make
decisions in early pre-production that
are going to have ramifications three or
four weeks into shooting and it's just
you know
understanding where everything where all
the pieces are and where you're going um
definitely a learning curve
a lot of it is about who you bring
to the table and i had an amazing crew
and they were you know they were full
bore into it and ready to go and kept
everyone safe and
despite some you know pretty big effects
with flamethrowers and things uh it all
worked out
so you said ramifications three to four
weeks into shooting can you give us an
example of maybe something you learned
that had to change a part of the process
later on sure i mean there's a lot of
like stunt work where you know for
example there's a sequence where we've
got rain bird
being thrown up into the corner of a
wall which is a wire pull with stunt
people pulling pulling him his stunt
double back up into the wall
and you want it big right you want it
big and exciting and of course it breaks
the wall um so then you're like oh we
gotta i'm gonna fix this wall we gotta
reinforce this it's stuff like that
where
everything goes in practice without a
hitch and then you get to those moments
um
and yet you know that i believe that's
the take we use because right there's a
lot of power to it so
you prepare for everything and then you
have to spin if you need to i can
understand that all right going back to
the script phase now i have a feeling
that there's a whole lot of answers to
this question i'm about to ask but can
you name something from either the
source material or that original film
that you absolutely knew you had to
incorporate in your own film but then
can you also give us an example of
something that you know you pinpointed
and strove to i guess either change or
maybe evolve in a way that's specific to
your fire starter yeah i knew from the
beginning that lot 6 the lot 6
experiment needed to be a part of this
film um how it was going to manifest
what we were going to see of it was
going to be different than the original
film but that was crucial it was crucial
for the storytelling and for
understanding things
and it felt like i could do something
interesting with it
in terms of changes
the role of captain hollister
um
i felt as though we had seen the
character martin sheen portrayed in the
original adaptation i'd seen that guy
before
and so i thought
i thought we could make a different
character here somebody with kind of a
different perspective and then getting
gloria rubin in for that role was was
amazing and she really she really gave i
think a
a really nuanced take on the sort of
character that we've seen before in
movies the general who's running the
show who you know has the country in
mind versus the individual i felt like
she did something interesting uh
particularly with kind of going with
this motherly route that she does i have
more questions about changes but i'll
save that for the end when we're talking
spoilers uh first here i was reading the
uh the production notes and it said that
you know when you signed on you and
scott together i think it said
solidified the script with your combined
vision so it made me curious what wasn't
in the original draft that you wanted to
bring to the table when you first joined
the project yeah i mean the luckily
a lot of it was there it was more just
drilling in onto some things so i think
you know
the biggest piece for me is the
relationship between andy and charlie
and the kind of parenting child
relationship
and so i think
i really wanted to focus even more on
those discussions of i mean i make it it
sounds boring but i want to focus more
on the discussions of how to parent and
the tension in like how do we take care
of this child and she's a ticking clock
she's a time bomb she's you know things
are going to get worse what happens when
she gets upset i wanted to play with
that suspense and so i think you know a
lot of it was navigating that stuff
um
and then you know in terms of stuff that
i wanted to put in there lot 6 is
another example of i think the original
vision of lot 6 was more akin to the
first film or the book and i wanted to
give it a different spin i wanted to
show a different version of that okay
i'm doing i'm putting up the spoiler
warning for our viewers you could talk
about everything freely and like i i
have ideas in my head for this
particular question but i'm wondering
for you is there any particular big
change you made to the source material
that you know proved most challenging to
pull off or maybe you're you're most
nervous to see how viewers receive it so
rain bird is the biggest change to the
you know
in terms of the characters um
when i first read the script the the
ending that's in our film was on in the
script and to me it was almost like a
seven moment like when i first saw seven
and like the what's in the box
scene it was like wow that's bold and
that's different and i love it and so
for me i called it the frankenstein
ending because i wanted the monsters to
walk off together um
and so
keeping that was key um
and
i was nervous about it and whether it
would work and whether people would buy
it
um so part of it was
just kind of reverse engineering to make
sure that people understood who rainbird
was as without getting expositiony um
and it but it's what i'm i'm really
proud of i i feel like the ending did
exactly what i wanted it to all right
i'm glad you brought up rainbird because
one of my last questions for you here so
again i was reading the production notes
and one of the things it said was that
you built an incredible backstory for
rain bird with michael so are there any
details from that that you can share
that maybe we don't see in the movie but
we can kind of feel influencing the
character along the way yes 100 so he
a lot of what michael and i came up with
is in the film it's just not said so
it's his clothing it's his music it's
the tattoos so if someone were to go
through the film and kind of pause on
the rain bird scenes if you paused and
looked at his tattoos and looked at what
each of them means it will tell his
story the one big piece i'll point out
is there's a sequence in his apartment
where the camera scans past a drawing
board with all these drawings that he's
done
those drawings
tell the rest of the movie from that
point in fact the very ending shot of
the movie is in the center of that
drawing board
because
of what rainbird's real ability is is
hinted at there in that you know it's
essentially he can see the future um and
so all those pieces his past in the lot
six trials his future how he identifies
with charlie it's all it's all there
it's just you know you see it for like
20 seconds
now i'm gonna have to go back and
re-watch it and like pause frame by
frame and find all the details
all right i gotta let you go big
congratulations on the movie and can't
wait to see yet another one all right
awesome thanks so much